let's do a little review of what the fed
funds rate was and it's a little bit too
thick
the fed
funds rate
and then we could move into something
that you've probably heard in the same
context and they're they're often
confused and that's the discount rate so
the federal funds rate
and then there's the discount rate
and they are related and they kind of do
move together but they are pretty
different in their actual implementation
so the federal funds rate this is a
target rate this is the target rate
at which the federal reserve wants banks
to lend to each other so let's say that
i have and i won't draw the balance
sheets every time now let's say i have
bank one
see this is bank number one
and this is bank number two
and let's say this bank over here has a
surplus of reserves i was already using
green but i'll do that in gold
just so we can reminisce about the gold
standard
so let's say it has a surplus of of
reserves and bank two needs them right
and let's say right now that
bank one is willing to lend it to bank
two if bank two
pays bank one a six percent
overnight rate and let's say that the
the federal reserve they say you know
what that's above our target rate we
want banks to lend to each other for a
lower interest rate so we want to do
open market transactions or open market
operations to lower this rate and the
mechanics that they do it by let's let's
draw
the fed's balance sheet i'll do the fed
over here
i'll do them in
magenta that's too thin
okay
nope wrong tool
there we go
so that's half of it and then this is
the other half
so let's say that this is the fed's
current assets and in a couple of videos
i'll actually show you what the fed's
balance sheet look like before all of
this craziness started what it looks
like now
but that's the current the federal the
federal reserve's assets this is their
liabilities
and then their liabilities are going to
be a little bit smaller than their
assets and they have a little equity
although their equity is a little
different than traditional equity there
really isn't a lot of upside you just
get a dividend on it but we won't go to
the details there but the mechanism that
the fed
uses to do these open market operations
is they essentially print money
so the federal reserve will do is
they will create some
notes or some actual reserves
so these are federal
reserve notes or as we know them the
dollar bills that are sitting in your in
your wallet or the things that could be
converted to dollar bills that are
sitting in your bank account the the
bits and bytes in some computer database
someplace and they can't create out of
thin air they have to have an offsetting
liability and their offsetting liability
are federal reserve notes outstanding
federal reserve
notes outstanding
right this is just saying hey we issued
this so if someone comes back to it we
have this liability and this is issued
even though these federal reserve notes
i'll circle in yellow are issued by the
federal reserve bank this is a federal
reserve they are backed by the full
faith and credit of the u.s government
and we've talked a lot about what that
means but needless to say we're just
going over the mechanics so what they'll
do is they'll take these dollars now
and they'll use these dollars to go buy
treasuries from people out in the world
it could be me it could be my my my
grandfather it could be even some of
these banks and so let's say that
there's you know right now somebody
is holding a treasury let me see if it's
if it's me
i hold a t bill
i hold a t bill
the federal reserve will use that money
let's say i own a ton of t bills i'm the
richest man in the in the country
could even be china china holds a lot of
t bills
they buy the t bill so then this becomes
this asset is no longer federal reserve
notes it's now a t bill
i'm writing t bill over that
and then i'm no longer holding a t bill
right because i sold it to the
federal reserve bank i don't know i sold
it to the federal reserve bank i just
sold it in the market i don't know who
bought it might have been another guy it
might have been another country but it
happened to be in this case the federal
reserve bank and now i'm holding
reserves i'm holding money
as we know it i'm holding a federal
reserve note and what am i going to do
with that federal reserve note i'm going
to deposit it in banks right and so i'm
going to take this federal reserve node
let's say i have a couple of bank
accounts or i you know whatever just the
sake of simplicity i deposit some of it
in
this bank account let's say i deposit
some of it in this bank account just for
simplicity
so what happens now
now this guy
has more notes to lend out and this guy
needs less right so demand has gone
demand has gone down this guy needs less
so demand
has gone down
from this guy and supply has gone up
from this guy
and we know that if you need something
less but people have more of it the
price of buying it or borrowing it is
going to go down so this guy has more of
it and this guy needs it less all of a
sudden
this guy is not willing to pay six
percent to borrow it and this guy's
actually more desperate to offload some
of these reserves and get some interest
on it so this guy's going to lower the
rate he'll charge and this guy is going
to lower the rate he's willing to pay
and maybe it goes down to five percent
and the federal reserve can keep buying
or selling treasuries to adjust what
this happens they could do the opposite
if they said wow you know rates are a
little bit too low let's say whatever
happens rates are at three percent and
the federal reserve doesn't like that
and wants to raise the federal funds
rate which is the target rate that banks
lend to each other then they could do
the opposite thing they could take this
t bill right this was a t bill
and they'll sell it right so they'll
take this t-bill and they'll sell it to
someone else
you know maybe this guy right here
so this guy
he's got a dollar bill so his dollar
bill actually i won't draw it there his
dollar bills are going to be sitting at
one of these banks
let's say his dollar bills are sitting
at one of say he's got a couple there
and a couple there
so when the federal reserve sells this t
bill to this guy
this guy might do a wire transfer to
that party or check or it doesn't matter
but
either way you look at it these reserves
disappear
and they go back into the federal
reserve and when they go back to the
federal reserve they offset this
liability and then the currency
essentially disappears but the real
result is that all of a sudden then
demand would have gone up because
there'd be few fewer reserves in the
system demand goes up and then the
supply would have gone down because
there's also fewer reserves in the
system and now this guy he's like well i
have less to lend out i need more
interest in order for me to lend it out
and this guy says wow i'm more desperate
than ever to borrow some reserves i'm
willing to pay more and so the rates
will go up to four percent
now all of this works well assuming a
world where banks are willing to lend to
each other at some rate there's some
rate at which you know this guy says you
know what i'm willing to lend to this
guy because i know he's going to pay me
the next day and it's just a matter of
just supply or demand and these tend to
be overnight loans they tend to be very
short-term loans so they tend to be very
very safe but what happens in a world
what happened let me draw the same two
banks i think i overdrew
so this is bank number one
and this is bank number two
and bank number one had more reserves
bank number two has fewer bank number
two needs reserves let's say people are
worried about bank number two all of
their depositors are starting to get
scared
and they're starting to pull their
reserves out
right and we all know that these banks
don't keep as enough reserves to fulfill
all of their deposits actually let me
draw bank number two's balance sheet
let's say this is bank number two's
balance sheet
they have
they have some equity hopefully
they'll have some deposits
let's say all of these are deposits
they'll have some deposits
they have to keep some reserves
right so that's an asset and depending
on their their reserve requirements but
they'll have some reserves
in case people want to take out their
money from their checking account and
then the rest of these are assets that
they invested in and the bank makes
money by making more money on these
assets than it has to pay out in
interest it makes money on that spread
now what happens if this bank its
condition starts to get a little bit
weak people start to get afraid and the
deposits start to
start to people go to their atm start
pulling their money out and and if
anything maybe they'll start depositing
it into a safer bank or just stuffing it
under their mattresses right this bank
says oh no all of a sudden i have a
liquidity issue because sure maybe that
much people withdraw their money i have
enough reserves to pay that
but then then if another guy comes along
then that's going to deplete my reserves
and then when the next guy comes along
i'm not going to have any reserves left
and there's going to be a full all-out
panic when i you know i told this guy
that i could give him his money on
demand and all of a sudden if i can't
give them on demand then we're going to
have this huge banking panic and then
everyone else is going to want their
deposits and then i'm going to have this
huge liquidity crisis
in a normal situation like that i'd say
hey bank number one i need some reserves
and just like i did in the first half of
this video this guy would lend and
you know this guy would lend reserves
and then this guy would give this guy
interest but what if this guy is scared
of bank number two too he's like wow
that guy's in a tough situation he's
faded seeing a liquidity crisis i don't
even know what his assets are worth
maybe his assets are actually shrinking
and that's been happening lately maybe
he made a bunch of bad mortgage loans i
don't want to lend to this guy and this
guy becomes a pariah of the banking
community no one wants to lend to this
guy
but at the same time it's in no one's
interest for there to be a run on this
bank because if this guy can't pay one
of his depositors and that's this is
kind of a prime weakness of the of a
fractional reserve system is if there's
just one weak link in the banking system
and people lose confidence maybe this
guy was the only bad bank out there and
people start taking all their money out
the first guy
who can't get his money back he's going
to call up the press and say my god the
banks aren't good for the money and
maybe everyone there's a run on all the
banks because people don't know which
banks are good which ones are bad
so to prevent this
the federal reserve has something called
the discount window
so let me draw the federal reserve's
balance sheet again
and the fed the discount window is
essentially
a lender of last resort
to the banks
so there's some type of you know federal
funds rate let's say the federal funds
rate is at six percent in a normal
environment this guy would like to get
that guy at six percent but let's say
that's broken and this guy is really
desperate he can actually go to the
federal reserve
he can
he can go to the federal reserve and
borrow directly from the federal reserve
so once again these are the assets of
the federal reserve
these are assets these are the
liabilities this is the equity of the
federal reserve
and the federal reserve in this
situation now
they'll print notes
so federal reserve notes or reserves
either way and these are the notes
outstanding liability
and they will lend it to this guy
they'll lend these notes to this guy
and in exchange this guy has to give
some collateral to the federal reserve
so let's say he had some other assets
here that are hard to sell
right that he couldn't find liquid or he
didn't want to sell them in a hurry so
he'll just keep it as collateral with
the federal reserve and these are called
repurchase transactions it's essentially
just your collateralizing alone and i'll
do a whole video on what a repo
transaction is but the big picture is
this guy is desperate no one else is
willing to lend him money so the federal
funds rate is now a non-issue so he goes
to the discount window and borrows
directly from the federal reserve as a
lender of last resort and the rate at
which he borrows the interest that he
pays this guy that is the discount rate
so that's the rate that a bank pays to
the federal reserve when it can't borrow
from another bank overnight and in
general the discount rate
the discount rate tends to be
higher than the federal fund rate in
fact it always is right because you
don't want people if the discount rate
was less than the federal funds rate
then you'd always have people using the
discount window all of the time instead
of using instead of borrowing from each
other but we'll see in future videos
when times get tough this gets used a
lot more historically the discount rate
was about a percent higher than the
federal funds rate to encourage people
to lend to each other or borrow from
each other
but in the recent past the spread has
gone down and now all of the rates are
almost zero but we'll go with that in
more detail but it's a key differential
when the federal reserve talk talks
about setting rates they're usually
talking about setting the federal funds
rate
and the discount rate usually moves down
with it but it's always going to be a
little bit higher than the federal funds
rate this is for lending of last resort
this is for
everyday borrowing between banks to make
sure that everyone has the reserves they
need or they don't have too much and
they can get interest on it anyway see
in the next video